Ilia adds i deal with this that things
fall apart of their own accord merely
because they age that that's the first
motif in the flood story and that's only
to say that if you build something it
decays if you build something and you
just leave it the hell alone
it will soon not work right and that's
entropy so one of the reasons that the
flood always threatens is merely because
of entropy and you see that reflected in
the Egyptian story because one of the
reasons that Osiris falls prey to Seth
is because he's old you know he was a
great hero when he was young and created
the Egyptian state like the men of
renown but now he's old and it's worse
he's be willfully blind but that's the
next thing but the fact that he's all is
just to start things fall apart of their
own accord so once something is given to
you you have to maintain it just to
ensure its continued existence and so
you actually you actually have a
contract with most of the things that
you own it's like a it's like a moral
contract let's say you have a car
well you've decided that you're going to
sacrifice to have the car and so you you
performed an ethical calculation but the
car was only worth the sacrifice as long
as it functions as a car and so what
that means is that to justify the
sacrifice you've made to have the car
you have to maintain the car because
otherwise you're acting out the
proposition that the thing you
sacrificed for actually didn't have any
value and so you're obliterating that as
a useful contract and you run into the
situation where the car will just
deteriorate of its own accord and then
you won't have a car at all well so
let's say how do you speed the process
by which your car deteriorates well
that's easy
you're driving it along the road and it
starts to make a ticking noise tick tick
tick tick tick and you think I should go
have that ticking noise checked because
you've heard it and then you think nah
it won't matter it's like yeah probably
it'll matter and what does matter mean
well matter is mother that's chaos to
you no matter but what it means is that
that little ticking noise is the
birthplace of time at in your car that's
a good way of thinking about it is that
it's your first indication that the
dragon of chaos is going to manifest
itself in your car that happens when you
I've got a funny story about that so I
had a friend in in graduate school
someone I really liked but I wouldn't
call her mikela mechanically inclined
let's put it that way and she had an old
Honda and those things were notorious
for rusting out this is 30 years ago
when they were first produced they
weren't adapted well to Canadian winters
and we used to go in her car in her
Honda and it got a little on the scary
side because it was so rusty underneath
that you can actually see through the
floorboards and that actually made me
nervous because if you can see through
the floorboards that means that they're
not really floorboards what they are is
like rust and so I mentioned the fact
that that might be a problem to her a
couple of times but she was sort of
blithe about it and one day she was
driving down st. Lawrence Street in
Montreal which is the main street
running roughly north and south and her
hood popped up it bent and popped up
spontaneously and so she was pretty
curious about that and so she was with
this friend of hers who was just as
clueless mechanically as she was which
is really quite remarkably clueless and
so they pulled off into a service
station and had the guy come out look at
it and well he he opened the hood
obviously and what had happened was the
body had fallen off the frame so and
what had could happen was the shock
which is like supposed to be attached to
the car had pushed up through the
through the hood so literally the car
body had like fallen onto the ground and
but she was she managed to drive the car
okay so look that's I wouldn't exactly
call that willful blindness because
perhaps there was an element of willful
blindness she didn't know anything about
mechanics but you get the point right
it's like let's say she would have been
in a fatal accident you might say well
you can shake your fist at God for
producing the circumstances but you know
the fact that you could see through the
floorboards that's probably something
that you might have paid attention to
and so it's always the question is if
things fall apart around you to what
degree is it the mere tendency of things
to degenerate entropically because they
do that of their own accord or have you
sped the probability of decay by failing
to pay attention when when our little
snake manifests itself inside your
paradise